was there a feature that almost happened
for this project that didn't quite make
it it's a lot of almost [ __ ] yeah that
happened that [ __ ] said oh man yeah I'm
gonna send that and all that's why I
[ __ ] that all [ __ ] I don't need no
more all boss features [ __ ] know how
to get in contact with me they can call
me I don't think I ever asked another
rapper for a feature ever again I'm good
on that [ __ ] on video I'd like to point
out that we met Drake together and Drake
said he'd get on a record but he also
said he'd give me 50 made a bet what you
did he said he'd give me fifty thousand
dollars if the sons went further than
the Warriors two years ago and they did
oh you cashing in on that [ __ ] I don't
know I mean I haven't seen him since
damn he ducking you but you were there I
was right there you can confirmed this
he didn't say that [ __ ] he said I give
you 50 Grand if the he said the sons
wouldn't go into the finals he did Eric
LaRock was there he did say that
so Drake did say that Drake owes me 50
bands yeah he do Drake you do open blue
leg calf 50 bands I can't stand on that
I want my percentage good